it is the 29 year old jacksonville
florida native mike clevenger on the
mound that's his overall numbers as far
as with cleveland and san diego this
will be his fourth start since joining
the padres and since then he's two and
one with a three era this will be his
second start remember his first after
the trade was against the angels at
angel stadium so the battery is mike
trout grisham center myers right
swinging at a miss mike trout oh what a
slider
i i did not see that slider and the
first one that was a swing of the miss
and the got fletcher with the last one
i've never seen in those other couple of
stars clevenger throw a slider like that
trout's probably thinking the same thing
is jaime berea on the mound today for
the los angeles angels making his fifth
start the 24 year old
pretty heavy on the slider also a
four-seamer two-seamer change up
he likes to throw that pitch opponent's
only ending 214 off of jaime
machado 314 16 homers 47 runs batted in
machado lines this to left field and
that's going to get in
justin upton to the backhand machado
headed for second base so is the throw
but manny will slide in safely with a
double with two down here in the first
inning
stay hot manny
last 30 games almost hitting 403.97 11
home runs he's driven in 34 and a little
two out lightning here two down machado
at second base to bring up eric hosmer
andre is trying to score here in the
first inning the one pitch coming up
in the air to left field down the line
towards the corner it is gone two-run
home run
slices his way right off the western
metal supply company building two run
shot for hosmer his ninth of the year
and the padres jump out to the
two-nothing lead
fat cleanup for eric hosner why not
clean up the bases that's what you're
supposed to do double machado opposite
field homer for hosmer
oh taking a selfie there in the dugout
nice bad news
my clevenger comes out after one inning
and it is adrian morihon who comes into
this game you said just the test see how
he feels see how he was going to do yeah
whether he'd be okay shorter start in
his career just the one inning so the
angels have a base runner to get things
started here in the second trailing two
to nothing and shohei ohtani will be the
next batter for the angels and he does
drive this one out to right center field
towering shot and this one is gone
big fly ohtani sounded just like dabber
tied at two good to see that type of
swing against a left-handed pitcher as
well for shohei ohtani 2-0 count showed
some patience got a pitch to drive and
he did so
seventh home run 24 rbis
and as usual when shoei otani gets a
hold of a baseball exit velocity of 109
miles per hour crush that out tie ball
game at two this average has slipped
under 200 at 199 for the former padre
that has driven out toward left field
towering shot and that's going to be
long gone back to back jacks
3-2 halos second deck for jayla
and just like that the powerball 81 home
runs down the season for the halos a
turn of events here today
is anthony bembum
breaking ball and that is ripped out to
right field this one has got a chance to
go what it does
big fly for anthony bamboo
halos extend their lead it's four to two
what about the catchers in back-to-back
games for the halos two yesterday for
max stassi and boom with ben blasts
going
376 feet
third home run off maury hone in the
second inning for the angels yeah and
all those balls have been squared up
ahead of just about everybody but unable
to put them away
third two down shohei ohtani
dealing lefty lefty ohtani swinging a
miss what a great fastball what location
up and in under the arms he had no
chance beautiful swing or not and tim
hill see you on the playoff roster you
know what i mean two outs in the inning
now and we'll see what david fletcher
can do he will be the next batter
and it turns on it sends it to left fam
on the move and he dives to make the
catch in left field
tommy fam lays it out makes the grab out
there nicely done he's not even running
off the field i would take a look at
that
so he doesn't catch it that's the first
thing right it comes out
when he hit the ground that's a big run
here big add-on run yeah butterfield is
about to get ejected i think he may have
been the third base coach who is yelling
out at bill miller the crew chief and
that may be the day for butterfield
i like the placement of the runners and
now joe madden out to talk about it some
more with bill miller
two walks two hits for rendon this
afternoon
back toward the middle but right to
profile shading him perfectly and that's
gonna turn into a double play we'll head
to the bottom of the ninth
two on two down last of the ninth mitch
moreland to pinch it
here comes the 2-2
this is now left center field trout
coming in he will make the catch light
that baby up as the angels pick up the
victory by the final of five to two